while you're making a contribution to
the create your own adventure story you
may find that your pull request can't be
merged because of merge conflicts here's
how that could happen and how you could
fix it
suppose you fork the original repository
on github clone your fork then make a
change in a new branch and push that
change to your fork in the meantime
someone else changes the original
repository on github if there are emerge
conflicts between their change and your
change then your pull request will not
be able to be automatically merged since
there's no way to resolve merge
conflicts on the github site you'll need
to resolve the conflicts within the
clone on your computer to do that you'll
need to get the conflicting changes from
the original repository into your local
repository which you can do by adding a
remote recall that you already have a
remote setup called origin that points
to your fork but you'll still need to
add a remote that points to the original
repository and many people named this
remote upstream adding and fetching the
upstream remote well add branches like
upstream slash master into your local
repository so that you can merge the
upstream branch with your local branch
for example I created a pull request to
add an option of stop drop and roll to a
page of the story where there was a fire
in the meantime though another change
was made to the same file to add an
option to turn on the chocolate
sprinkler that change conflicts with
mine so I need to resolve the conflicts
before my pull request can be merged so
in this diagram this is the commit
adding the chocolate sprinkler and also
this one and my change was to add a stop
drop and roll option these commits were
the same in all the versions since I
created my change in a separate branch I
want to make my master branch the same
as the master in the original repository
so I'll run git pull upstream master to
update my master branch to the latest
commits from the original repository
then I'll merge the master branch into
my change branch and I'll push both the
change branch and the master branch to
my fork I didn't need to push the master
branch but I thought it might be nice
now since this whole process only
contains commands that you've already
learned I want you to try doing this on
your own before I demonstrate how to do
it on the command line as a reminder the
steps
to carry out our first add the original
repository as a remote in your clone
next pull the master branch from the
original repository into your clones
master merge the master branch into your
change branch locally and resolve any
merge conflicts and finally push your
change branch to your fork which will
automatically update your pull request
if you run into trouble I'll demonstrate
how to carry out this process in the
solution if you didn't run into this
problem because your pull request was
merged without conflicts I encourage you
to get some practice by making a new
change and then not making a pull
request for it then you can wait for
someone else to make a change and then
get some practice bringing your fork up
to date even if there are no merge
conflicts you can still get practice
merging once you've finished this
process check this box